[Music]
there is hardly an animated series that
can claim as many fans as rick and morty
the series which has been running since
2013 has a total of five seasons
comprising 51 episodes and there's still
no end in sight so far though there
hasn't been a spin-off of the hit show
but that is about to change as stated by
the hollywood reporter the us channel
adult swim is set of origin spin-off
called rig and morty the anime takashi
son who has already been involved in
countless anime and manga productions
will be in charge of the new project
both anime shorts rick and morty vs
genocider and summer meets god rick
meets evil were also made under his
direction in terms of content the plant
series is not expected to stray to for
from the original thus there will still
be plenty of multiverse adventures just
in a different style nonetheless takashi
sano emphasized that overall the
upcoming series will stand on its own
sadly there is neither a release date
available for netflix nor any further
information about the series but as
usual we will keep you up to date
next year dune part 2 is already
scheduled to have its cinema premiere
those responsible have now finally
agreed on an important cast we are
talking about emperor shannon iv the
powerful ruler of the universe many
actors were considered for the job but
in the end pulp fiction actor
christopher walken made the cut that 79
year old american has played a long list
of disturbing or bizarre characters
which is why his casting as emperor
shadow the fourth appears to be quite
fitting other newcomers include florence
p west shannon's daughter princess
ireland and austin butler who embodies
the villain fade ralph the harkonnen by
the way the 31 year old actor will soon
be seen as elvis presley in the biopic
elvis by baslerman fate raltha is the
nephew of baron vladimir harcon and is
said to be in no way inferior to his
uncle in terms of ferocity and
cleverness in the first film adaption
from the 80s by david lynch the
character was still played by pop star
sting as with the first part of 2021
danny villeneuve will be directing the
film many actors from the first movie
will also be back most notably of course
timothy chalamet as paula traitors
zendaya as johnny and rebecca ferguson
as lady jessica
we are eagerly awaiting further news and
look forward to dune part 2 which is
said to be released on october 20th 2023
the civil court war between amber heard
and johnny depp has been going on for a
few weeks now and it still seems as if
there's no other topic for many film
fans now the 36 year old herd commented
on her role in the upcoming aquaman and
the lost kingdom because it was cut down
very much due to johnny depp's
allegations she's said to have
repeatedly received new and shorter
versions of the script and the crucial
action scene was even entirely dropped
from her part moreover she stated she
had to fight very hard for her role in
2018's justice league which was probably
at the high point of her marital crisis
with johnny depp she also recently
complained in court that many pr
appearances and even her relationship
with the l'oreal company had been
affected meanwhile however there is
little sympathy for her even among movie
fans who are not classic johnny depp
rupees after all her ex-husband had to
go through exactly the same thing and
it's unclear what will happen to the
respective careers of the two for johnny
depp though a comeback two pirates of
the caribbean does not seem ruled out at
least according to producer jerry
brookheimer there are two screenplays
for part six one with margot robbie and
one without her while at present depth
is not part of either script a decision
on this is to be made in the future a
surprising statement from brookhammer
after all a renewed partnership between
disney and dev is considered to be as
good as impossible the jack sparrow
actor only recently claimed that he
would not return to the franchise at any
price perhaps at disney they're still
waiting for the outcome of the trial it
remains to be seen whether they can and
will try to change steph's mind
nevertheless we shouldn't get our hopes
up too high one thing is at least in
sight and that is the end of the civil
trial this was originally scheduled to
end on may 27th and is unlikely to take
much longer surely a great day for
youtube recommendations which are
flooded with court case videos
last year warner brothers godzilla vs
kong provided a visually stunning
spectacle in cinemas and home theaters
at the end of march the responsible
parties officially confirmed a sequel to
the monsterverse film and in the
meantime they have even cast their first
leading role this refers to downton
abbey actor dan stevens who will slip
into an important but as yet unknown
role so far the rumors still persist
that the next monsterverse movie will be
called son of kong instead of godzilla
vs kong 2. as this has already been
implied in the first film behind the
camera we are counting on a familiar
face as adam wingard once again gets to
do himself the honor of sitting in the
director's chair it must be assumed that
shooting will start in the course of the
coming weeks or months however an
official release date is not available
at this time
it was only in february that homeland
actor rupert friend was cast as the
antagonist belisarius and rebel moon yet
it is already evident that this was only
a short-lived affair as he has already
left the project a mere three months
later as deadline reports there were
scheduling conflicts between different
projects which is why they now announced
the signing of deadpool actor adds crane
as a replacement this announcement comes
right on time since the shooting of zex
snyder's rebel moon already began at the
end of april the plot is still largely
kept under wraps we only know that a
peaceful colony on the outer edge of the
galaxy is suddenly threatened by the
tyrannical villain belisarius from now
on the colony salvation is in cora's
hands as she recruits the most capable
warriors on several neighboring planets
further her mysterious past is supposed
to be of great importance but that's all
we know about the storyline so far up to
now quite a number of actors have been
cast besides sophia boutella's cora and
adds crane as belisarius the cast also
features ray fischer as blood ex and jim
on hansu as general titus also newly
revealed has been the signing of three
actors namely the last man on earth
actress cleopatra coleman hawkeye actor
freyfi as well as halloween actress ryan
reese we are excited to see director
screenwriter and producer zack snyder
bring the cast harmoniously in front of
the camera there is currently no release
date for rebel moon which will
officially be available on netflix
there is news from disney's world famous
animation studio pixar as those in
charge announced this week weekend soon
expect a new pixar animated movie called
elemental this would be the 27th feature
film from the 12 time oscar winning
studio so expectations are high as usual
pixar also already published an official
synopsis including the designed movie
title via twitter there's talk of a city
in which fire water land and air
residents live together the two
characters amber and wade are the focus
while amber is associated with fire wade
is supposed to represent the water the
director is peter's son who already
worked on the pixar film the good
dinosaur in 2015 albeit not very
successfully denise reem who worked on
cars 2 among other projects will
function as producer in addition to
newly released concept art there is also
some backstory information about the
film there are no doubt some childhood
memories flowing in from director
peterson who as a child emigrated to new
york city with his parents and perceived
the city to be a place full of cultures
and languages certain elements can be
blended and others cannot which will
certainly be illustrated in a creative
way in the film we are definitely
excited and hope that director peterson
will have greater success with elemental
than he did with the good dinosaur the
movie will be released starting june
16th 2023 but it is not yet known
whether it will be shown in theaters or
if it will be only available on disney
plus
which news did you find most interesting
this week feel free to let us know in
the comments there were also plenty of
new trailers this week such as for
she-hulk the boys and the next predator
installment prey have fun watching
[Music]